let's go next to let's go to Mike from
Georgia at the 706 area code Mike from
Georgia what's going on hey David how
are you doing good thanks okay so I had
a question so uh we hear a lot about you
know in the debate that they asked
right-wing framed questions but don't we
need right-wing frame questions that are
going to be taking on you know the the
Republican establishment or really just
the establishment and the whole yeah so
so you're asking a very important
question so here's the thing some during
during Democratic debates the point is
to best figure out who of the Democratic
candidates really it's for two things
whose policies do you most agree with
and we are also making judgments about
electability we are imagining the
candidates on the stage debating Donald
Trump so it seems like what you're
pointing out is at a certain point the
Democratic nominee is going to have to
face Trump and is going to have to face
Republican arguments therefore isn't it
logical for the moderators to be making
some of those Republican arguments in
questioning the Democrats is that sort
of what you're saying yeah yeah that's
here's the problem with it when the
moderator is framing up a question for
all of the people on the stage that's
not about asking a particular candidate
how something about their policy will
work when you frame the entire question
in a way that is a Republican slant
you're in a sense discrediting the fact
that this is even being discussed in
particular terms and that's why it's so
problematic if you have different
Democrats up on the stage and someone
wants a public option for health care
someone wants Medicare for all some
someone wants a phased-in Medicare you
know you have all these all these
different things you want that to be
debated in a way that is sort of fair
and neutral and let the candidates frame
their positions and if they want to
bring up
what it is that Donald Trump wants to do
fine when the monitor moderators a
priori framed the entire question where
the logical answer the right position is
one that is what Republicans are
advocating for or more to the right not
only is it not the point of the
Democratic debates it also is helping
the more conservative candidates up on
the stage and so we just don't want it
that's not the role the moderators are
supposed to have okay yeah yeah that
definitely makes sense I always kind of
found a hypocritical that they're
supposed to come off as a neutral force
and yet they seem to go in more towards
a Republican direction or really setting
up all these trap questions that you
can't really you can't really wiggle
your way out of unless you attack the
framing of the question that's another
good point which is that it to properly
handle that you're putting the
candidates in a position where they
either have to go after the moderators
for the framing which they should do and
I'm glad when they do it but that takes
time away from actually figuring out who
on stage has the best policy and so it's
also a distraction in that way oh yeah
and that's kind of like my problem with
debate other than the fact that I don't
know how much they'll they'll change the
course of the election because I mean I
feel like most people kind of have an
idea of who they want to vote for at
this point in the gun this late in the
game the debates will do very little to
change public support other than if
someone blunders terribly and they will
then be hurt but it is very difficult at
this point in the game to really gain
very much by doing well in the debates
because people are mostly familiar with
the candidates and with their positions
yeah all right well you pretty much
answered my question so thank you very
much David
all right thanks Mike great to hear from
you